[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author and my daughter is
my co-host today as we answer your
questions about triple eight eight two
five five two two five about your life
and your money triple eight eight two
five five two two five cabins in
Indianapolis whoops that's wrong let me
try it again Kevin's in Indianapolis to
uh start off this hour hi Kevin how are
you
hey Dave I'm doing well how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
well uh got a question my wife and I
have been talking for about a week or
two now we are trying to get some stuff
underway to start saving up for a
mortgage on our house uh back story is
we're about one quarter smart three
quarters down we were one quarter smart
off by living off of 30 000 a year
income for on her income so I could pay
my way through Master's School
three-quarter done we needed a reliable
car so I fell into that trap and I
bought a car years ago
um where we're at now is we owe about 21
800 left on the car
in one savings area we have about 19 000
and another savings area have about five
thousand
we are torn between being highly
aggressive with that 19 000 and being
mildly aggressive because we do have a
one-year-old and we're both kind of like
you know do we go for the full 19 or do
you go a little less wondering what your
advice would be on that
did you graduate
yeah yeah graduated got a double year
income right now I'm bringing them 125
gross 125.
gross yes okay and she's still working
and she makes 30.
yeah so we have 150 000 household income
yeah a twenty one thousand dollar card
debt
and twenty four thousand dollars in your
accounts
yes
and what are the what are they each
saved and what's the 19 000 in
uh it's over in a in Capital One it's
just over there sitting in a a high
performance CD or high performance
savings okay and then the other five is
where
it's just in our mutual Bank account
okay gotcha gotcha the five the five is
our kind of
um
hour three months we're just starting to
look at your guys's stuff a little bit
and when we're looking at our numbers
the five is kind of our about five
months
um savings we have a thousand emergency
but the five is there the five thousand
is about a four or five months yeah yeah
so what what happened Kevin was when I
was your age I went broke and lost
everything
Rachel was a baby and we couldn't pay
the light bill
and so from that experience I started
studying what is the fastest right way
to build wealth because I had built
wealth
the wrong way
and that's why I lost everything
too much debt
and in studying that and in studying
people who had built wealth I pretty
quickly discovered that the fast that
the people who build wealth not the
middle class and not the people who
wander around in a fog
with an opinion
but the people who had actually become
millionaires the vast majority of them
realize that their most powerful wealth
building tool was their income
none of them get rich on a high-yield
savings account
high yield savings account will not by
Def cannot mathematically by definition
make you rich because you're making
three or four percent
yeah
inflation is nine okay right yeah so
you're going backward all right period
so the bottom line is this the ones that
built wealth were the ones that got out
of debt and avoided that that put us on
the Journey of at Ramsey 30 years ago of
showing people how to get out of debt so
that they can build wealth more reliably
so that they can change their family
tree so that they can be outrageously
generous okay
so that's the premise on which we answer
all of these questions we want to take
you down that path and never in the
history of man has someone keeping a
twenty one thousand dollar car loan
around like it's a pet been a method of
Building Wealth
think about it we were we were really
aggressive with it to get to start so it
was sixty thousand dollars total I think
40 in two years and now we're looking at
it as when we do when we say let's just
say out loud that that purchase was
stupid
well yeah it was way out of your budget
you said that was the 25 not smart I'm
agreeing with you okay I've done Dumber
But but so you know all of that's going
to lead us to a pretty simple answer
yeah which Kevin is is to pay it off
today and then you're gonna have three
thousand dollars left as a buffer for
your starter or your emergency fund and
maybe step three which is your three to
six months of expenses but you make a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year you should be able to put several
thousand dollars a month in that account
and so we're not going to be at 3 000
but for 30 seconds the end of the next
month you should be at six or eight
thousand the end of the next month you
should be a ten or twelve thousand
dollars so we're not walking around with
a one-year-old with absolutely no money
as a way of life
it's just a momentary thing here by
Christmas you ought to have a big old
pile of money man
and that's that's where we're at where
we're both when we talk about it we both
see the like you're saying Dave with the
get aggressive and then four months you
have this and we're both looking at the
one-year-old who does have some medical
appointments coming up going should we
be just slightly safer and span it out
over a minute we're not gonna have a
medical appointment unless the child has
medical issues today you're not going to
have a one-year-old medical appointment
that is going to take more than three
thousand dollars
okay unless he has some kind of unless
he's struggling with something but if
he's going in for standard
checkups you know it's a couple hundred
bucks dude and you make 150 000 a year
I think you can handle it
could be aggressive with it highly
aggressive the reason would be that
that's the fastest right way for you to
build wealth get that emergency fund in
place a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses and then
with no payments at all now we save for
that house like crazy
and you can do it man I mean you just
you lean it lean in on a budget yeah and
I think Kevin too one of the the mindset
shifts that is important for you guys
just to say out loud with you and your
wife is like okay where we are today we
don't like it we don't like having we
had a sixty thousand dollar car loan now
we've done you know we've we've taken it
down to 21 000 we have some money here
we have some money there obviously
something is stirring in you guys that
you're not content with where you are
financially you know there's something
in you that's like man there could be a
better way which is why you picked up
your phone and called the show right I
mean like there's one in the bear cage
they're Named Dave bear named Dave uh
but so so my challenge to you Kevin
would be like to be do something
different try this way what we're saying
and again it's not gonna put you back
financially at all you guys have a great
income you're gonna be okay and there's
gonna be natural fear natural hesitation
to do something that feels a little
different but what you guys have been
doing if you keep doing the same thing
you're not going to be happy with your
results so you have to do something
different doing something different is
uncomfortable but push in even if it's
even if you're scared and comfortable
because you're gonna be okay you're
gonna be okay you're gonna be fine if
you pay attention
play through
good stuff
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
their wash and guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save forty percent off selected
products visit blinds.com today for more
info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
best-selling author multiple times over
and my daughter is my co-host today open
phones at AAA
825-5225 Nick is in Milwaukee hi Nick
welcome to the Ramsay show
you too how about how can we help
so I had a curveball to throw to you so
we are currently in baby step two about
50 to about 55 000 in debt that we paid
off um from 75 000 that's credit card
bills
um house Improvement and mostly medical
um and there's like car payments
involved uh we've been pretty aggressive
in step two I work about 15 hour days my
wife works full-time as well however we
got throwing the curveball
um in that we they just told us we have
about 10 grand worth of dental work we
have to do for all three of my teenagers
because they have to do get all three
enough to get braces the curve the major
issue is I'm a dialysis patient so on
top of this I get you know medical I'm
on the transplant list and once like
that happens that's going to be an
additional four or 500 a month that
would build interest just for medical
bills because of medical the medications
so my my major question is
how would we tackle this added deck for
the kids braces without having to go
into even more debt to get those done
because we have about 2 000 in our
emergency medical fund or emergency fund
just so once I'm out of work for about
three weeks once I get the transplant it
can cover that but with having this
curveball thrown at us with the kids
braces it's kind of put a little bit
more anxiety into the mix more than
there already is
what's your household income
um last year we brought in about a
hundred thousand combined okay how old
are your children
uh my boys are turning 14 next week and
my daughter turns 13 the week after
all right
okay uh
um I'm trying to think how to couch this
exactly number one are braces legitimate
absolutely
okay
um I think all of our kids or several of
our kids for me you didn't okay Rachel
or Denise and Daniel had braces so I
remember I remember writing checks for
this okay I couldn't remember which ones
it was yeah yeah they've all got great
teeth and it changed their lives but
anyway the uh um uh uh uh
uh so it's not an illegitimate uh
request or whatever but it's not a
curveball and it's not unexpected and it
is not an emergency
it didn't just suddenly happen last week
when they went to the dentist
you may have gotten new information that
made you realize you're going to have to
address the issue but the the way you're
using your words as is as if we don't do
it by the end of the month that we're
somehow going to have destroyed our
children's lives and that's simply uh uh
a dentist making a sale there that's not
a reality
so if we did the braces
six months from now
I'm not a medical doctor and I'm
certainly not an orthodontist but um but
but I I can you know I I suspect
Common Sense tells me that they'll
probably still be okay
all right that you don't have to do in
the next 10 days but sometime in the
next 10 months or 20 months we address
them and maybe we address them in
you know the the one that's the greatest
concern first and then we don't all do
all three at once and so the way you're
presenting this is if it's
um and it's nowhere near as important or
urgent as your situation is
your situation now you I can get excited
about making that a big deal right
you follow me yeah
and so don't don't let the emotions of
the teenager
yourself your wife
orthodontist trying to make a sale make
this a financial catastrophe that has to
be addressed by the end of March because
that is simply not reality
that's that's after I already said this
is a real this is something we need to
address and I'm okay with addressing it
I'm not saying it's not true I'm not
saying they don't need braces I I'm
saying when we do it how we do it is
going to be on our schedule not on the
orthodontist schedule
yeah that's kind of I think where my
brain has been freaking out because
where we've been so good going to the
baby step two we've really been tackling
it I mean I've worked like crazy hours
so when are you going to be finished
with baby step two
uh uh hopefully we're projecting
hopefully by January of next year that's
kind of our goal
so do the braces after that
okay that's kind of what we were
thinking but then you can handle it I
mean 50 000 bucks between non-january
you can cover 10 grand in braces after
that
you're that guy
my point is it didn't set you back it's
something you do after baby step two
that's where my brain has been freaking
out it's like oh my God we've added this
is going into the mix now we have to get
it done because again I worry about I
worry about them I can hear your freak
out that's what I was addressing yeah
it's it's not it's not as urgent I don't
think as you're as your freak out is
telling you yeah I mean you're yeah
braces that 15 years old one of them
that is you know got a got a real issue
and six months is going to make a big
difference that's a possibility I don't
know I guess it is
um I mean it might save you a year in
braces if we go ahead and get it done in
the fall rather than in the spring
you know then what's work one of them
into the budget but to stop everything
and have to do all of them this month
because you got fresh information two
days ago nah
okay yeah that makes sense it was just a
like I said the brain freak out was was
kicking in
well and
um
the the
Dental world has in it people that have
common sense and that are kind and
normal and want to help and want to
serve and it also has people in it that
are really good salespeople
that um you know and so I don't mind
even getting a second opinion about this
and maybe get a second if it's a ten
thousand dollar item I might want to get
bids
you know I don't why not it's it's you
know it's braces it's not like it's it's
a commodity I mean I don't know if I
find three or four other people and find
okay well this guy says You're gonna be
in them for two and a half years this
guy's this gal says uh oh using this new
technique we can we can be done in nine
months you know I mean you wanna learn
about stuff like that sure I don't know
but I I and your and your emotion Nick
like I get it it's understandable as a
parent when you go into any level of you
know appointment with your child it's
like this is what's best for them we got
it we need to do that and if they had a
sense of urgency naturally as a parent
if you're not calming down thinking
about the logic and having someone else
speak into it it's easy to get where you
were Nick like when you called uh as a
parent but sometimes when those when
that emotion it clouds judgment very
very quickly so yeah hopefully that that
helps to just take the earth I think
it's the urgency part like they're okay
they're okay and God forbid again if
nothing like crazy medically is wrong
long people go without braces and then
they end up getting them as adults later
in life you know what I'm saying like I
mean like that that happens too so
they're they're going to be okay unless
there's a more serious medical need
they're fine if they wait another year
yeah there's
I don't know the the medical things I
guess and and dentists are part are
dental is part of that are um
we none of us would lay people know
what's really going to trust them like a
mechanic being a mechanic they're like
this is wrong the unknown of it adds a
drama to all of us yes well any area of
your life yeah you know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I mean same with
cars we went out to dinner with a couple
and uh some friends and they were
talking about they took their van in to
get work and it came back like this
crazy bill of all this stuff they did
and they were like oh my gosh so then he
like ended up kind of researching he's
like they didn't need to do half of it
but he but he even admitted he was like
I didn't know so I was like okay I mean
you know cars better than I do right so
any part of life that you feel
inadequate you trust the experts well
you gotta you gotta dig in and so that's
that's the point is don't let the
emotion Drive the decision really get
some data points and I love the second
opinion idea because there's plenty of
people that have different ways they do
things different timelines and it's
that'll give you more peace too more
information you have there's a lot of um
really cool stuff
um that my dentist was telling me about
I mean they're tools they use that it's
Evol it's not a it's an iterating
evolving industry I thought you went to
the dentist Dave that's good way to take
care of yourself good for me yes that's
right this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Cruz Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage Anthony and
Lauren are with us hey guys how are you
I'm very good well honored to be here
thank you honored to have you where do
you live uh we're from a small town
called Fremont Ohio it's near near
Toledo okay fun good to have you guys so
welcome to Nashville how much debt have
you paid off we paid off 221 thousand
dollars all right wow how long did that
take took about 19 months good for you
and your range of income during that
time so we started out around 105 and
then jumped up to about 280. whoa okay
what do you guys do for a living so I'm
a podiatrist and I stay at home with the
children now okay wow I guess so good
for you guys so what kind of debt was
the 221 oh Sallie Mae oh the open diet
I think Lauren that this was Anthony's
fault I could be wrong
just a little bit okay so doc doc ran up
doc bills okay but then you jacked your
income how did you jack your income
threefold in 19 months yeah so 105 was
my first contract coming out of
Fellowship training and then just as the
practice got busier and you know
surgical volume picked up but so did the
income yeah and you happen to time that
right off the backside of a pandemic
yeah yeah that's very good too when
people are coming out going yeah this is
electric elective surgery a lot of times
right yep yep all right and so yeah wow
good for you guys yeah amazing so how
long have you been married so it'll be
seven years seven years okay so you
married him while he's going through med
school then yes and you guys were broke
living on student loans and you come out
but it sounds like almost immediately
after coming out you jumped on this well
so we have a little bit of a longer
story than that I guess so I I first
heard about you was about seven years
ago actually in November before we got
married in May and I was on rotation in
the hospital in Lima Ohio and we were
between cases and one of the senior
residents was talking to a nurse
anesthetist and I overheard him you know
oh yeah we did that we were on beans and
rice rice and beans and like okay that's
a that's an interesting conversation
over there so I I asked the senior you
know resident you know what what are you
guys talking about oh there's this guy
he yells at people for buying cars it's
a great show
so I thought I could I could check that
out so I would practice my suturing
listening to the to the podcast actually
went out and bought The Total Money
Makeover and then when I when I went
back to Lauren we were living both in
Cleveland at the time before we had got
married and I said you know when we get
married you know we're selling your car
we're gonna get out of it yeah I had a
couple thousand left okay on this car
yeah and he just wanted to get rid of it
right off the bat she's like well I
still need something to drive I said oh
I guess that's a fair point so so once
once we got once we got married then we
sort of combined our income combined our
finances we actually paid off her car
and uh she's and I had a student loan
yeah hair stylist so she had cosmetology
school we yeah paid both those out and
then two weeks into our marriage found
out we were married with Ava all right
sorry expecting Ava and so we sort of
went to Baby Step Zero for about four
years because about 15 months after Ava
was born Nora was born and oh my gosh 15
months apart yeah it was back to back
and then we were moving around the
country for my training I trained in
Indianapolis and then went to Florida
for a fellowship and so when we started
out at that 105 that's after actually
will was born and we were wow
yeah we're ready to put down some Roots
so that's when we sort of jumped out of
baby Sub Zero and and we went really
hard so there was about five years there
of just of job craziness kid craziness
like gosh and you're but you still kind
of kept it in a sense even though you
hadn't really fully started I know you
guys paid off some alarm stuff yeah but
it's like right when you got out you're
like we are on this which is impressive
to keep that momentum of the of the
longing to do it right in the middle of
kids and all that uh all the way to the
to 19 months ago yeah and then Hammer
Down yep absolutely yeah that's so great
was it hard to be making that kind of
money and continuing to live
like you're broke you don't want rice
and beans beans and rice I mean to be
honest with you I don't think the living
was that hard because we had sort of we
were under such a fine margin for so
long and yeah with little ones we were
sort of used to we didn't all of the
furniture in our house was hand-me-down
Furniture yeah everything was
hand-me-down so we were we were okay
with that
um but I think the hardest part was just
giving so much of that money just back
to the government back to the government
that that was really hard just uh that
was painful showing how all that all
those checks just straight to Sally me
so yeah that hurts our date nights were
going to Home Depot looking at
appliances that we'd want someday yeah
like just dreaming like someday
yeah
well that is a good point though because
you didn't have to go backwards in
lifestyle because for a lot of people
they're like oh they were living this
lifestyle and then they have to stop it
go backwards yeah but you continue to
consistently do what you guys have been
doing which is
did people think you were crazy
they didn't tell us to our face
they were nice to our face
that's fun well that's impressive you
guys I mean that's tell people the key
to getting out of debt is we both talked
about
um we feel like it's mindset you know
you have to be prepared to make all the
sacrifices and know that your life is
not going to be probably quite as fun as
it could be yeah I think uh there's a
quote that I I heard by Pope Benedict
and he says you know the world will
offer you comfort but you are not built
for comfort you are built for greatness
and I feel like that I just sort of feel
like that really applies to to this
scenario you're you're going through the
discomfort now so that later you have
that and you can also be a source of
comfort for others it's just another way
of saying you know live now like no one
else so that later you can live like no
one else yeah so good good very good
congratulations and Rose thank you I'm
proud of you thank you how's it feel to
be free oh it feels great yeah I mean
you got a lot of young doctor age you're
walking around they don't even know what
Freedom looks like they've got so much
hanging around their neck don't they
yeah well yes and you just walked right
past them well you just did did you just
blew past them and now you got three
little babies and you've changed your
family tree life is great man well done
you two let's do how long didn't fit in
with our lifestyle that's not what we
wanted so it's awesome we didn't like
Sallie Mae in the spare bedroom the old
lady put her on the street she's ugly I
like it way to go guys hey we've got the
live and give bundle for you the baby
steps millionaires book you're going to
be there in 20 minutes thank you and uh
of course Total Money Makeover you can
give that to somebody if you want and
the Financial Peace University
membership and all the babes and if you
ever bet that so yeah bring the babies
up and let's see their names and ages so
Ava is six Nora is four and will is
almost two all right very good not far
off of Rachel's ages
very good you guys congratulations thank
you all right have Ava and Nora and
William been practicing their debt-free
screams yes they have they're ready are
you ready kiddos you ready here we go
all right Anthony and Lauren Ava Nora
and William from Fremont Ohio 221
000 paid off in 19 months making 105 to
280. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream you guys ready three three
two one
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Applause]
that's the sound of a family tree being
changed oh we scared the little William
got scared
that's what it sounds like of our family
tree to be changed
I mean you make uh 280 a year she's at
home full time with the three now and um
you got zero debt oh my goodness do a
lot there's gonna be a lot of change
it's gonna be a lot of possibilities a
lot of things they can do a lot of
people they'll be able to help and
certainly those three littles will have
a completely different life because of
this last 19 months of sacrifice
absolutely very very very well done
that's how you do it folks live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else that Pope Benedict
quote is really good it's really good
not built for Comfort but built for
greatness yeah and that's it it's like
you just want to be comfortable and
you're not comfortable with the Comfort
crisis we read that book yeah same idea
it's like it pushes against everything
that you were actually you really were
created for on so many levels we have
too many people searching out Comfort
rather than searching out greatness yep
and um yeah Michael Easter that's the
author of that book Comfort crisis we're
gonna have him on are you really we're
gonna have we're gonna do an event with
micro and me and him and some others
talking about the labor crisis in
America we'll be announcing it soon a
big big live stream coming up this
is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
Cruz Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us it's a
free call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five when was the last time
you were excited about Monday
What If instead of waking up exhausted
and dreading you're weak you actually
look forward to work because you're
doing work that you love work that
mattered worked where you got traction
where you were functioning in your
passions hey that's why career expert
and Ramsey personality Ken Coleman
created the get clear assessment to help
you discover your top talents passions
and a clear mission statement that'll
help you find the work that the world
needs you to do when you find that
you're going to be very fulfilled you're
going to make more money and you won't
be thinking about stupid stuff like
quiet quitting
instead of reaching for uh communism
you'll Embrace capitalism
you know I mean it's a good idea when
you you know when you actually find what
you love that's what ends up happening
this week only the assessment is ten
dollars off the sale ends at midnight on
Friday get the deal today go to
ramseysolutions.com get clear now what
we know is that since the first of the
year the Ramsey Show ratings and
viewership and listenership and all of
our various formats are way up thank you
for that we appreciate that but what
that also means is a bunch of you that
are newbies around that when we're
talking in code like baby steps and debt
snowballs and stuff you don't even know
what the flip we're talking about so uh
because we like this tribal speak and uh
you don't necessarily know the tribal
vernacular yet hey we want to help you
move along your financial Journey your
life Journey go to Ramsay solutions for
free and click on the get started button
we'll tell you what your next step is
and begin to indoctrinate you into the
tribal lingo but show you why we're
doing what we're doing and you can begin
to plug in to say this is where I am and
here's a good next move from me and
according to Ramsey this is what I
should do I wonder if I should do that
or not and we'll show you get started at
ramseysolutions.com Logan is with us in
Dayton Ohio hi Logan welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi sir how are you doing
better than I deserve sir what's up
hi me and my wife have been kind of
getting into wasn't your podcast and
we're getting ready to start our debt
snowball here soon and one of the best
ways also help with that is to increase
our income I am currently a mailman I
make about 50 000 a year my wife is a
travel rest for a nurse she makes
anywhere from 100 to 150 000 a year but
she's not wanting to do that for much
longer because we have a one-year-old
and a newborn
um so I'm thinking about trying to
switch jobs possibly
um one idea is like truck driving
because you can start anywhere from
seventy thousand dollars to ninety
thousand dollars but I'm worried about
uh with the post office that you have
benefits of attention and your insurance
health insurance is getting paid after
you retire
um our goals are to build a house one
day and retire early so I'm just trying
to figure out which way you know is is
best to take you know the better pay now
or to you know take the long road with
the post office
if you take better pay now
and spend it all
then you're going to end up with none of
the things that the benefits would have
done
if you take better pay now get out of
debt and become wealthy
you can buy your own freaking health
insurance
that's kind of what I was hoping I just
didn't know like what you know would
thirty thousand dollars a year replace a
pension and health insurance easy and
stuff like that easy easy okay that's
what I was worried about I just I just I
want you know a good life for me and my
kids and do you mind if I answer a
question you didn't ask
of course
um I'll make a statement instead
I think you're taking the truck driving
gig only for money not as a long-term
career goal that you think this is going
to be awesome and you're going to love
doing it the rest of your life
that's probably true yeah I think I
wouldn't do that
I think you can find something else that
makes eighty thousand dollars that gives
you a high quality of life or make 70
with you learning a skill that you want
to do the rest of your life and you move
from 70 to 80 to 90 to 100 over time
yes sir so I want you to I want you to
take that get clear assessment I was
just talking about a few minutes ago and
think about where you want to be working
and I want you to go get your income
increase but I want it to be with
something that gives you purpose
fulfillment and then at the end of your
life you haven't dreaded Monday every
day and just done your duty as a good
husband and Dad and right now that's
what you're doing you're just saying I'm
going to do my duty my wife wants to
come off the road and I'll go make some
I'll go handle the discomfort of being
an over-the-road truck driver in order
to make more money so she can do that
and you were just you know you're just
being a good man and I appreciate that
about you
that's what I'm trying to do yeah but I
think I think there's a way to do both
it's going to take more effort and a
little bit more mental strain for you to
think through it and figure it out it's
not as obvious as just going oh I can
make more money doing that I'm gonna do
that but that's going to get old fast
man do you have anything Logan in like a
dream world have you even let yourself
go there if man what if one day I could
do X Y or Z
you could do anything you wanted to do
and money wasn't a problem what would
you do
it wasn't a problem I had the time to go
back to school I'd love to be like a
psychologist or a lawyer
um but that's a lot of money and that's
that's you know seven eight years of
school
okay
that's what you're you're right about
but there's something in those is it
helping people what's What What In Those
careers is it that you find interesting
wow I think that's the mental aspect of
it
just you know understanding people and
why they do things and uh yeah I'm
always I I don't I'm not saying I like
to argue but I'll tell you what I have
to get in like a debate with somebody
just just for the fun of it I don't know
I may like that so
yeah pretty much
yeah I mean I the same kinds of things
motivate me exactly and that's how I end
up here uh in a weird way but um so it
may be that there's other ways you can
manifest those exact same desires other
than two careers that have long uh
education paths yeah and I would say
though to Logan in the meantime in your
wife's home with a toddler and a new
baby
and I know jumping from job to job isn't
ideal but if they're like if you guys
were in a more urgent situation you know
for me driving for for six months while
you figure out the long-term plan could
still be in play just to get her home
like yeah that would be okay okay but I
wouldn't I wouldn't say let's just sign
up with this with no no exit no I would
have I would have a goal I want an exit
strategy yes yes but in the meantime as
you call our show today if you guys
don't want to wait six nine months till
you figure something out if there was a
quick move you wanted you both wanted to
make sooner you could do something in
the interim until you really found that
thing
yeah as a step absolutely so Austin uh
we won't have you pick up and give Logan
the um the paycheck to purpose book and
the get clear assessment because I just
told a truck driver he needed an exit
strategy so
man well he said he's going to be a
truck driver then oh he will be a truck
driver he'll be getting off at the exit
I can just tell you so
much okay I'm glad I missed it that
makes me
I'm enough plugged in you're part of the
family you're part of the family if you
missed it because I missed it until it
came out of my mouth but oh you gotta
love it all right I am uh well known for
those wrong metaphors at exactly the
wrong time so it's it's kind of a
classic Dave move open phones here if
you want to talk about your life and
your money triple eight eight two five
five two two five thank you for jumping
in
Rachel I think it's important to
reiterate for everyone I remember Earl
Nightingale who did the The Talk The
Strangest Secret many many years ago
with that baritone voice he would say
too many people
spend more time
picking out a suit of clothes than they
do their career
and you're going to spend the next 30 or
40 years maybe at least some kind of
version of what you start what road you
start down and so don't just pick
something for the money
and and the other assumption you can't
make is that just because you're doing
something you love you have to make less
I don't know where that comes from
it comes from the same place that as
soon as I get laid off the next job I
get I'm going to make less why don't we
assume we're going to make more
and why not if you were doing something
you loved would you not be more
enthusiastic more creative more engaged
and work harder at something you love
and therefore end up making more
but we think we have to go work for
Mother Teresa or something or go in the
non-profit and the peace corpse in order
to be doing something holy or be doing
something that is of meaning or purpose
or be doing and that's just absolute
bull just wrong yep yep so don't don't
assume less assume more and that's not
some kind of prosperity or abundance
thing it's just factual
I mean if you're a better at something
because you love it you should make more
at it hello
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author multiple times my
daughter is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
your money open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Valerie
is in Oakland California hi Valerie how
are you
I'm doing well Dee thank you for taking
my call it's a pleasure to be on with
you today thank you how can we help
so I was recently in a car accident that
um totaled my car or they're writing it
off wow are you okay totally yes I'm
fine and grateful to be here just to be
alive
um so they're writing my car off and
offering 15. so I use my car for work
and I'm a physical therapist that does
home care so I need a really reliable
car and of course my car was paid for
I'm on baby step number four I have no
debt I was working on my emergency fund
I had about a 11
000 in it trying to get to 25. and
um I don't know what to do about a
vehicle now of course I have a rental
until the end of the month but just
feeling pressured to
make a decision well you were driving a
fifteen thousand dollar car and your
fifteen thousand dollar check
you go buy a 15 000 car
yeah it's not going to have all the
bills in with it it's the same car
that car should have a market value that
was totaled of fifteen thousand if
you're getting a fifteen thousand dollar
check you should be able to buy that car
again
right I can't find that car again it was
a 2014 Toyota Camry fully loaded there's
millions of 2014 Toyota Camrys if
there's anything in the United States
it's Toyota Camrys
this is not exactly a rare vehicle
okay but I've only got
me one and I've been searching I just
haven't been able to find one okay but I
mean you can you can find a car for
fifteen thousand dollars that is
comparable in equipment reliability
quality miles to the one that was
totaled
we know that because they gave you a
market value of they gave they have to
pay you by the terms of the auto policy
market value for the car so if you had
sold your car you would have sold for
fifteen thousand dollars
okay but I I was working a plan though
uh well now I don't know it's just an
inconvenience I guess it is it's a huge
inconvenience it is Valerie is the
timelines what's stressing you out
because you're like I'm researching but
I have two more weeks I'm assuming until
your rental is up
um right I've got two more weeks for my
rental how about this Valerie what if
you paid one more month of a rental
and you said or two or another an extra
week of that just to give you some
breathing room to be able to find this
because you should be able to find it
yeah so Valerie let me tell you what's
happening okay and what I'm pushing
against and this is why it's messing
with you I've not been fair I'm gonna be
fair now I'm gonna tell you what's going
on okay
almost every time for 30 years I've
talked to someone in your situation for
some reason the human brain says we need
to move up in car we need to celebrate
the fact that our car was totaled by
getting a much better car
and so you've been out looking at new
cars
well but they jumped in front of you
when you were going down the road
that car dealer lot is swung around at
the traffic light and there it was in
front of you
right but I was looking for a used car
on that car lot and today they're
telling me that the used cars are
costing more than the new cars yeah this
would be who that told you that the new
car dealer
that's a bunch of crap okay that was
true for about five months during the
back end of the pandemic when the
Mississippi ran backward and used cars
went up in value it's the only time in
history those two things have happened
in one year it's absolutely a miracle
the Red Sea parted that year too so but
no it's not used cars are not more do
not cost as much as new cars that's not
true anymore it was true for 20 seconds
and it's not true anymore so you know I
mean if you ask a new car dealer if you
need a new car that's like asking a dog
if it's hungry
okay okay so no you need to go look for
used cars you need to jump on auto
trader some of these other things I
wouldn't even go to a dealership like I
mean I would just look online I mean you
know I just said just to be able to not
have the emotion of being there on the
car lot just go do some research online
I want you to fight about the idea of a
fight with yourself about the idea of an
upgrade because there's something about
the human brain that says when we total
our car we have to get an upgrade
and that's what I was that's why I was
wearing you out about the value of your
car a while ago because I was trying to
break through that in your brain because
it does all human brains seem to do it I
I've noticed it I I've uh but it's like
okay time to get another car oh let's
get a better one you know and so there's
something about the Trump the trauma
that you've been through with the car
wreck there's something about this I
didn't want to deal with all this now I
got to deal with it so while I'm at it
now it's an emergency for me to have a
twenty thousand dollar car instead of a
fifteen thousand dollar car so I'm gonna
pull five grand out of my emergency fund
which you should never use your
emergency fund for something that is not
an emergency that's why we call it an
emergency
fund and so yeah this is what but
there's something about that so I'm just
that's a good point because I just kind
of rattle you a little bit Valerie and
say hey go find a 15 000 car and then
you're right back on track yeah because
I was sensing
a little bit of this urgency and panic
and frozenness of the timeline of like I
only have two more weeks so giving her
that extra week might calmer but I think
you're but yeah you're you're spot on
because
especially if she's already looked at
new cars she said yeah the the bells and
the whistles like she said and not that
you can never have a nice cartoon like
make that a goal that's part of this
plan once you get your emergency fund
and you move on to Baby Steps four
through six and you do some stuff you
could step up and car then I mean it's
not like you'll always have to drive a
15 000 car but for now it's gonna be the
wisest move to continue to go down the
baby steps
and let's just say out loud
that a 15
000 it's a dollar car
today
is so much better than anything I drove
for the first 30 years of my life
I mean the quality of the vehicle oh
yeah the amount of life left in the
vehicle was more than a new car in 1974
Hadley I mean it was you know I mean so
they they don't make them like they used
to thank God
you know I've got a 1960 Corvette and it
is cute and it's a frame Up Restaurant
when we put a new engine and drivetrain
in it so it's got a good engine and
drivetrain in it but you can't stop the
thing in a 10 acre field with those dad
gum horrible 1960 breaks they don't make
them like they used to thank God every
time I go around the corner it Corners
three times you know it's a marshmallow
and it's supposed to be a sports car so
it's cute and it's an antique but this I
you know the fifteen thousand dollar car
in today's world is amazing dad gum nice
car
I mean it's it's you're gonna be okay
everybody you too Valerie but everybody
out there just this idea I gotta have a
forty thousand dollar car to be like be
subsisting or something is it's America
crazy this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Reginald Cruz Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money it is a free call hey guys if you
want to help us out we can use the help
and some of you have been doing that and
we appreciate it number one you can
share the show
if by telling somebody that you let's do
it on the radio or watch it on
television or if you want to share your
YouTube link or your Spotify or your
Apple podcast link or talk about where
you listen to talk radio whatever it is
share it tell people about it help us
help us help us help us we are not
spending 300 million dollars a year on
marketing and we don't have a football
stadium like
um I'm sorry I got things I got
allergies um and so we don't have uh
anything like that so the only thing we
can depend on is you guys to help us
spread the word and it's working when
you spread the word and leave a
five-star review soon like today tell
people you love the show if you if you
want to do a one star review there's
other shows I can direct you to because
if you can't say nothing nice don't say
nothing at all that's what mama said so
there you go and of course we also want
you to follow the show subscribe if
you're in a digital format like a a
podcast or YouTube If you subscribe or
you follow it helps the algorithm and
drives it as well so we're moving on up
uh the uh the marketing team the radio
guys they're the broadcast guys their
goal is for us to be in the top ten of
all Apple podcasts uh we are at Lucky 13
today oh lucky 13 of all podcasts in the
world there's a two and a half three
million of them and we're number 13.
lucky 13. so we but really I mean we
shouldn't probably hover there I'd
probably rather be 15 than 13 and I'd
really really scary I'd really rather be
five there you go so uh let's get up
let's get back let's get in the top ten
uh I mean it's working for us it's good
but you guys spreading the word this is
what does it thank you thank you thank
you for that our question of the day
comes from our sponsor neighborly great
company they're your hub for Home
Services when you need to make repairs
schedule routine maintenance or find
local help on Improvement projects
neighborly is your source for Reliable
home service providers in your area
things like Mr Electric or Mr or Molly
Maid go to neighborly.com and start your
search
so today's question comes from Jonathan
in Kansas we have some money that we are
waiting to invest in silver or gold
some people are saying that the
centralized banking may fall apart and
gold might actually become the standard
again what do you think of that I think
some people spend too much time on the
internet
everything that's on the internet is
true Abraham Lincoln said that it's
every uh
every conspiracy theory in the world no
but seriously though it is uh it's
always there though I mean like gold is
all it's that's all it's been a fear
type of idea you need to invest in it
you need to get it because of the fear
of everything is going to crash yeah and
let's let's address two different
subjects here okay one is we have some
money we're waiting to invest in gold or
silver okay first we'll address that one
okay never invest in gold or silver
okay the way you pick an investment
is you look at the track record of the
right of Return of the investment
so if you're going to buy a house
for investment
and the area around the house is
blighted crime ridden
full of trash and the values are going
down because the neighborhood sucks
that's the track record of the
neighborhood Common Sense would tell you
don't buy a house there
right
you look and see are the homes well kept
or are the cars up on blocks
you know you look and see you know is
every other house foreclosed on on the
street and boarded up and codes and rat
infested you don't buy on that street
you look at the track record you look at
the track record of a mutual fund it's
been open 30 years it's averaged 12.2
percent that's a good track record right
but I I look at a look at the track
record of cryptocurrency full of fraud
sucks most everybody lost everything you
look at the track record of Bernie
Madoff really bad idea everybody lost
all of their money you've got conned you
look at the track record of gold for the
last 60 years it has averaged around two
percent a year
that sucks
it's not magic because it's gold
it's a it's an investment
silver the same way horrible rates of
return over a lifespan of investing yeah
there's been little blips based on fear
or greed but gold sucks
as an investment well what if the
Central Bank the central bank's not
coming back you conspiracy bozos
the Senate at the Central Bank collapses
in America
you need bullets you don't need gold
because all hell's going to break loose
I'm gonna say bottled water bottled
water and bullets and I'll take your
bottled water if I've got bullets
unbelievable I mean it's going to be
Anarchy right it's a central bank
collapses every business that you can
name right now that you're familiar with
will have gone away simultaneously
I mean it's similar to a nuclear winter
right okay you're going to have a whole
new government
you're going to have a whole reset of
the property rights and economy this is
not like gold it's going to help you in
that
no it's not so the central bank is not
going to collapse oh my God
just because one bunch of duber venture
capitalists and startup Tech Guys ran
their little San Francisco Bank into the
bay does not mean the central bank is in
trouble
because it's not boys and girls it's not
so two things don't get into conspiracy
theories because it leads you into
stupid but Investments like gold you you
can get into them but just oh you can't
get into it listen and be entertained
but don't make your financial decisions
based on them okay okay but these were
all about decisions these are all about
financials that's right we don't want to
do financial decisions for those of you
that are new to the show Rachel is our
resident conspiracy theory Queen
she believes things that most not that
animals don't believe but she loves to
see what I said two or three years ago
is no fact so I'm just telling you well
I you know when it comes to coveted
conspiracy theories they've all no it's
not just that it's a bunch of them it's
a bunch of other stuff yeah a bunch of
other stuff okay there we go we could
have a whole show Dave let us have a
podcast please we have been people have
been begging for yeah as long as you
don't do it on this show you can have a
podcast you go do your own little
podcast and you can do that over there
in the corner I don't We're not gonna do
that to this show this show Works
hey hey all of you that want Rachel to
do it it's all the Stranger Things by
Rachel
no weird stuff by Rachel weird stuff
conspiracy theories by Rachel and have
George on because Jordan they'll listen
raise your hands God there's a bunch of
weird people no it's because some of it
is
true
it is it's true it is area 51. now this
is so great
that's like welcome to Thanksgiving at
the Rams season triple eight eight two
five five two two five Brandon is in
Milwaukee hey Brandon how are you
hey thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
so I got a little bit of a debate with
my wife's um
so I'm kind of new to the Ramsey life
she is a Ramsey she listens to the
podcast so she doesn't know what I'm
calling in case I'm wrong so we on our
primary residence outright and then we
have five duplexes and our principal
interest taxes Insurance everything is
2300 a month for all of them how much
debt on the five duplexes total debt
uh like 280 I believe What's the total
value on the five duplexes
uh
600 ish okay so you got about 50 you got
a little over a 50 Equity position well
done
how can we help yeah
so she she says that
you say we should only buy rentals in
cash absolutely
but I thought I heard you say
that as long as our mortgage is under 25
percent of our take home that would not
be your rental that would be your home
you should only buy rentals in cash I
own several hundred million words yeah
as far as these these things go I'd get
them paid off in three years or I'd sell
one to be able to do that but uh pick
out one you don't like and sell it and
get yourself out of debt you get out of
debt dude you're gonna make more money
in real estate you ever made in your
life I mean the best thing ever happened
to you
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you guys I can't even explain how
excited I am for the new money and
marriage getaway event here in Nashville
Tennessee on October 19th through the
21st so we have a full weekend planned
for you and your spouse and it's it's
gonna be so much fun you don't want to
miss it and here's the thing that life
is crazy and it's really hard to find
time for just you and your spouse so we
wanted to give you a chance to unplug
from your day-to-day life come to
Nashville have a little weekend getaway
and focus on your marriage so Dr John
deloney and myself are going to coach
you on all different things around your
marriage including your money and
budgeting with your spouse you're going
to learn new ways to communicate so that
will make better connection and you'll
get realigned on the stuff that really
matters so that you have a stronger
future going forward in your marriage so
this isn't just a typical marriage
conference we have an amazing date night
experience plans for you plus time to
reflect with your spouse and apply
everything that you are learning to your
marriage so we've got a lot plans for
you a lot of good food fun surprises and
you can get early bird pricing on all of
it with for just 699 dollars a couple so
you guys that is a deal for the entire
weekend that's the price so talk to your
spouse and then go to
ramseysolutions.com events to get your
tickets to the money and marriage
getaway here in Nashville Tennessee in
October
this will be held at the brand new
Ramsey Event Center which we opened this
week today yeah yeah we had a big
kickoff today was our first group
meeting up there we had a family a uh
Ramsey family Ramsey team uh devotional
up there and uh it was it was pretty
incredible Michael W Smith hung out with
us and let us in some praise and worship
and Dr Michael Easley spoke and it was
pretty pretty special morning thanks to
some of our really good friends here in
the area so come out make sure if you're
in town we're doing one of these events
at the Ramsey Event Center you're going
to want to see it it's a pretty pretty
extraordinary every building and we're
really really proud of it it's just a
fun place to host
ESS money thing's gonna be great there
it's perfect for that all right up next
is going to be Elizabeth in Grand Rapids
hi Elizabeth welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave and Rachel thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so my husband and I right now
um own our home and our own business a
construction business that we do
seasonally and this is our first year
owning our own company we made about 150
net income wow and now my dad has asked
us if we want to buy the
buy an hour and a half away
um we haven't ever had any debt and the
business would be to buy that about a
million and then eventually to buy the
property is about 3.1 million
and we're not sure if we should do it or
not
um I think the business the family
business is something my husband would
enjoy doing and it's definitely a lot
less physically demanding right now with
our construction business it is a
physical job
so it could get harder long term
how old are you guys
uh we're 34. okay what kind of business
is it
they sell like industrial equipment like
forklifts okay
one of my best friends was in that
business okay
um and that business the past two years
has made about 500 net income on like a
low year 200. okay
and um on average of the last three
years well your last three years are
weird but
um in a normal World average the last
three years times about four is about
what it's worth so it's probably not a
bad valuation on it
um and uh so how much do you guys know
about the inner workings of the business
we know
husband will go like step in for my dad
so he can go on vacation so he's able to
do that am I right uh I I think I
remember hearing that most of the money
is made on the service
and the ongoing uh maintenance and
issues around the the equipment more
than it is on the actual sale of the
equipment the margins on the actual sale
aren't that great
he makes most of his on the sale I would
say because he's more in the
refurbishing and reselling okay so he's
selling reselling used stuff instead of
new okay yep all right cool a lot of it
some new to new and used all right uh
well I think the things you guys have to
ask yourself first the reason I'm asking
these questions are the questions you
need to be asking yourself hey do you
want to do this for the rest of your
life just because it's available doesn't
mean it's the right thing
okay and do you want to live in that
town
I mean an hour and a half away is that
where you want to live is that where you
want to have your life because the
answer until today was no
you wanted to live in Grand Rapids and
you wanted to run a construction
business until today
mm-hmm
yeah and be careful that
uh you know something that your dad
wants is you do it for that reason you
don't want to do it at all for that
reason dumb reason we work on that
around Ramsey all the time don't do
something just because Dave once you do
it you gotta do something because God
calls you to do it it's because it's
what you're supposed to do it's what
you're wired to do it's what you're
designed to do you're going to love
doing it
um because business is too dadgum hard
would your dad still be in the business
Elizabeth
no he would like to
treat why doesn't he buy it
uh too much responsibility
your brother's not reliable
not really no not as reliable so what's
going to happen to your family when you
fire him because it doesn't sound like
he needs to be working there
yeah but he's not reliable
he's reliable and he can do that he does
that well
owning the business
okay so now we got another thing you got
to work through is hey what are we going
to do with him and B how are we going to
manage that relationship uh as him as
you know you're his new boss
that that's a thing one of my concerns
that's a thing okay but now let's back
up then so the valuation doesn't sound
bad the real estate's a separate
transaction that doesn't sound bad you
can sign a lease uh guaranteeing that
your father-in-law or your father
doesn't lose his mind on rent and run
you out of business with that so you
lock down the property like you would if
if it was a different landlord you'd
have a long-term lease on the property
so you could have a stabilized business
right yes and at least with an option to
purchase so at least with an option to
purchase on the real estate no I'm not
going into debt a million dollars to buy
this under no circumstances what I would
do is this
um I would work for pennies in the
business
as little as your family can get by on
and give your dad in other words if we
figure out that the thing's making a
half a million and uh you guys are going
to take 50 000 out of it and live on
fifty thousand a year and give him
everything over that until we get to a
million
no no no no no no I don't care what he
said I'm setting the deal up and it's
going to be in pay on paper in writing
that all of his income up to a million
dollars for the valuation of the
business comes to him from profit above
50 Grand and you live on 50 Grand or
whatever number you set and so if there
is no profit above 50 Grand he gets
nothing that year
that's this deal because otherwise you
are in debt to him and you are going to
mess this up it's going to be a problem
it's not going to be run like he wants
it he's going to want to put his hands
back on it and you're going to have a
former owner walking back through the
place with his muddy boots while you're
trying to take over leadership
can you tell I've done this before yeah
no I'm worried about that too yeah
because your dad started this didn't he
consideration
okay all right so we have to have some
clear
boundaries and the deal has to be in
writing as if it wasn't family
and don't you know don't don't half but
do your your business dealings because
it's family because you end up
destroying family
so you should understand the structure
of what I'm saying he can have all the
profits above X until until we get to a
million dollars
it sounds like you could pay him out in
about three or four years
if you did that but if there's no
profits because there's like I don't
know a pandemic or something
then you're not out of business and your
father's not foreclosing on you
because oh I'll work my whole life not
deserve my money I don't want to hear
this crap okay I want to hear it at all
because this is our deal
profits is where you get your money from
no profits no money
and that includes if the narrative well
brother doesn't do his job so we don't
have profits
doesn't make any sales by the way you're
a sales guy this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thanks for joining us America Rachel
Cruz number one best-selling author and
my daughter is my co-host today Elise is
with us in Charlotte North Carolina hi
Elise how are you
hey Dave hey Rachel thank you so much
for taking my call I appreciate it sure
what's up
so I um I'm kind of in an interesting
situation
um I recently finalized a divorce
um I have about 150 000 cash on hand as
a result from the sale of our home
um and I am not sure if I should put it
into retirement
um I only have about seven thousand
dollars in a rollover Ira
um or do I put all that towards the down
payment of a house in the somewhat near
future
um you kind of don't really know what to
do uh or where to start how old are you
I will be 33 this year how long were you
married
uh it would have been six years last
week
what happened
uh
unfortunately I'm sorry I'm so sorry
okay thank you
um
okay generally speaking
uh you're in a position right now
because you've been through hell
uh traumatized traumatized will be the
technical term right
um and a uh Dr John deloney would say
that when you
um
have your trust and your confidence
violated
it takes some of your self-confidence
away
the ability to believe in yourself to
trust you know I I trusted him so I must
not know how to do this right kind of it
takes some of your confidence away does
that sound right
yeah that sounds about right I've been
sitting with this money for about
uh almost a year now and I've really
just I haven't know I've been kind of
scared of doing anything like that you
don't trust yourself like you used to
before the garbage
and that would be like a normal human
thing by the way okay and the good news
is you'll heal from that and you will
begin to trust yourself and you'll begin
to discover that actually you are very
trustworthy it's him that wasn't
it but it'll occur to you and you'll
start the emotional healing I'm quoting
Dr deloney now okay this is not I'm not
a an expert on this but it's also kind
of common relational sense and it's
stuff you've been living in so I'm so
sorry for your heart broken
that's just it's just an awful thing
you've been through
so um for sure so I know it is not a
retirement thing if you want to own a
house right now
yeah that'd be okay buy you a house put
that as your down payment
but there's not a law that says you have
to buy a house right now
I mean you can put the money in in a
simple if you want to say I'm going to
take three years and I'm going to put it
in a mutual fund and I'm gonna go
backpack Europe I don't know I don't
know what you're going to do but uh you
know I'm saying I don't care I'm not
doing that but
um sounds like a lot of work to me but
the um but people do that thing I've
heard you know you know so uh you know
it's what do you do for a living
I'm an account manager for a tech
startup okay have you got family in your
area
yeah I'm really blessed to have my
parents about uh 45 minutes up the road
I've got great friends here love
Charlotte never leaving so you got a
good environment to work through this
shovel this garbage out right
you knew what I was going to say then
look at that okay did I quote him right
no you did you did perfect okay good
because you probably listen to him as
much as I do then okay all right so um
yeah
I just don't want you to feel forced to
do something like uh by some Financial
rule that doesn't exist in your head
like if I if I don't invest this I'm a
horrible person and I'm stupid no that's
just not true you're in a transition
period and parking money and a
transition period is a normal thing so
if you want to buy a house I'd probably
buy a house but if you don't if you want
to just put it in a CD and say you know
I'm going to just kind of Coast for a
little while longer and enjoy the ride a
little bit and then I'll buy a house I
don't know Rachel what are you yeah how
long have you guys been separated at
least how long have you been on your own
I've been on my own for almost two years
now almost okay so the so the divorce
took that long and then it's been
finalized so now you're ready to yeah
make that next step so I mean yeah I
mean is owning a home something that is
at a goal for you here soon is it
something that you would love to do
yeah uh I think with rent in Charlotte
I'm sure anybody that's in Charlotte
listening right now can attest to it uh
rent's just so crazy and I think after
being a homeowner for so long I I can't
stand I feel like I'm throwing my money
away
um
here's what I would suggest though I
would suggest buying a home that is
um
not unique
it's not special it's not weird
it's three bedroom two bath on a street
with houses with three and four bedrooms
and two baths you know I mean it's a
house that's very predictable and the
reason for that is you can sell it
if you want to move on with another
stage of your life five years from now
but for now you can scratch the home
ownership itch get back in the game so
to speak and just go buy something on a
nice you know even a condo but something
is very predictable that it's going to
be easy to sell because it's good Market
but if you get this weird little thing
that's special and there's only four
people on the planet that like it and
you're you're one of them you know then
you've got a hard time getting out of it
later you see what I'm saying
yeah no I feel like you you called me
pretty well okay yeah that's that sounds
good yeah just get something that's kind
of a little bit generic and you put
paint colors or decorating that that
gives you your personality but it
doesn't have to be weird to show off or
something right now because that's the
other thing is is
um I predict that five years from today
your life is going to be completely
different
and you're probably not going to be
living in this house
and I want you I want to give you I want
to give you a way out of this house
that's very predictable and you will
have enjoyed the investment of real
estate because you can sell it for a
profit yeah and I think making a move
Elisa since it's especially since it's
been two years you've been on your own
for two years yeah uh there is a
confidence boost there that I think is
great I mean I think putting this down
on a home uh of something that you love
that's yours there's a sense of dignity
that's kind of restored in that and so I
yeah I mean I'm a huge fan I wouldn't
rush into it if there's something that
you don't absolutely love if you want to
buy it because you want to own a house
fine but not because like I feel the
social pressure that I'm wasting money
or I'm dumb if I don't get this money
invested or something I don't want you
to do that I don't want you to feel
impressured
but if you want to fight go take your
time select a good house that is
marketable when you get ready to resell
it so you can make a good profit
and you're not trapped in the silly
thing then yeah I definitely would do
that no question about it open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money Rachel it's good to
remember for everyone out there and her
case illustrates that the personal
finance
is more personal than it is finance
and what that means is not that you get
to customize the law of gravity you
don't principles or principles but it
means that you're given the situation
right now might dictate
a a different angle on a traditional
financial situation yeah you know and so
if you've lost a a spouse you don't need
to rush out and be a suddenly a great
mutual fund investor you know if you're
brand new out of college and you're
getting married in five months and you
want to go buy a house and she's never
seen it dumb idea
you know so that personal situation
changes what normally would be a good
idea to buy a home for a young couple if
you can afford it you're in good faith
but it changes its uh situational yeah
absolutely because as well as seasons
change so fast in life and I feel like
that's even something that I'm running
into with our seasonal life with with
kids and we have friends that are now
upgrading homes because they've
finalized their family and now they're
okay we need some more space and some
more room so just how quickly things
change as well just keeping that in mind
I think allows you to make decisions
with a little bit more of that
flexibility so even in her case you call
it finalizing your family
I've had some family I wanted to
finalize ours is finalized I can tell
you that
we're having three kids
and we're done
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships this is a
baby steps Millionaire's theme out we
are going to talk to real millionaires
not your brother-in-law with an opinion
who votes wrong real millionaires we're
going to talk to people who really have
money got it and kept it and learn how
they did it what did they do so that you
can be like them
see the problem with this whole
millionaire thing is all of this wealth
thing is half of the information out
there running around is mythology
let me just help you with this Rachel
Cruz by the way Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author my
co-host for this baby steps millionaire
female or if you are a millionaire a net
worth millionaire which is the only kind
of millionaire there is that means your
net worth is a million dollars or more
net worth is defined as what you own
minus what you owe equals 1 million or
more
your assets monitor liabilities
when that is a million dollars or more
well that's too much money this is not a
moral construct it's a math thing
well no one should have a million well
that's not it's not we're not asking
your opinion about that all we're saying
is it's a math thing
well it doesn't feel like it's enough
it's not a feeling it's a math thing if
you have a one million dollar net worth
or more by definition you are a
millionaire I don't even care if you
feel like it or not you are it's not a
feeling it's not a moral construct it's
a math thing it's an accounting entry
and so that's all it is and and it but
it isn't Milestone and an indicator of
becoming wealthy and Rachel the greatest
mythology spreading around our culture
today and sadly it's taken root to the
point that a lot of people who are
otherwise intelligent believe the lie
and I think it's because they just
choose to that all wealth today is
inherited
yeah I think that's a that's a mindset
that's been around for a long time that
if you're wealthy it just happens you
just yeah because you were a trust fund
baby it was given to you somehow and in
the millionaire study it's 79
received absolutely zero inheritance
nothing another five percent
received an inheritance but it was not
enough mathematically to make them
millionaires in other words grandma left
him five grand
okay that doesn't that doesn't make you
a millionaire but yes you did get an
inheritance another five percent
received substantial money like quarter
million dollars
after they were already millionaires
so 5 and 5 and 79 would be called 89
that's 9 out of 10 millionaires
mathematically are not millionaires
because of an inheritance
and that's from the largest airtight
piece of research largest study ever
done on millionaires in North America
that Ramsey research did and we had an
outside research firm look over our
shoulder to make sure we're right
because we knew the Communists wouldn't
like the answers
the wealth inequality people okay and so
yeah it's not fair well fair is where
the tilta world and the cotton candy are
okay fair is those guys got up left the
cave killed something in drug at home
they did not inherit it I'm sorry if you
don't like that call the wambulance
that's how it really works out here in
the real world now that's who we want to
talk to but if you inherited the million
I'll talk to you if you hit the lottery
yesterday God help you but I'll talk to
you okay I don't care where your million
came from we want to talk to you because
we want to find out your story and share
it with people because it inspires
people to let them know it really is
happening in America today as best we
can determine there's somewhere around
12 to 15 millionaire 15 million
millionaires in America today it's
pretty substantial and it's just a
little over 3 000 billionaires in the
world
but a billionaire is way different than
a millionaire if some billionaire is
listening right now they're all in
please
but a billions of thousand million yeah
yeah it's a lot okay so if you have a
hundred thousand dollars you're
light years closer to being a
millionaire than a millionaire is to
being a billionaire you're one-tenth of
the way there they're one one thousandth
of the way there do you know what's
funny about this mindset though around
millionaires I don't know if you feel
this way but just just even on social
media or like when I just uh hear
conversations around millionaires
I feel like I find it's either no one
can do it the middle class can't get
ahead there's nothing there's no
possibility that you can live in today's
world because of of the math that if you
made you know ex you know 70 80 90
Clarity is gone and I missed it and that
yeah you like you just can't afford
things anymore there's no way you can
save mathematically it won't work it's
either that or people are like yeah
million dollars that's not a lot I need
more and it's these people that are in
like crazy real estate investing and
they're like you can have 200 million
dollars like No And it's this like oh
you're talking about Tic Tac and it's
like inflated that it's that millionaire
is just not that's not enough you need
to be like a Deca million and they keep
going and going going yeah so it's just
so funny the mindset I'm like I just
feel like I hear from both camps yeah
and so frequently and both of them are
wrong yeah versus and again the people
that are actually believe it and are
doing the steady investing they're
paying off their house they're becoming
wealthy over a social period of time
they're just not the ones commenting
stuff we teach will lead you to a one to
a 10 million dollar net worth depending
on your situation it will not cause you
to be a billionaire
that you cannot you cannot be a 401k
billionaire it's not mathematically
possible
okay it's impossible but the vast
majority of the millionaires we studied
were a paid off home
five six hundred thousand dollars and
900 or 800 or
1.2 million in their 401K in mutual
funds and they're 50 50 40 50 years old
and so they've got a million and a half
dollar net worth and it's a 500 000 paid
for House a million dollars in mutual
funds and almost all of them fell in
that category I mean very very few uh
you know hit the lottery uh I'm this or
that now listen if you want if you want
to be
a billionaire
I mean we're talking about most the time
you own or you grew and sold off a
business
uh and that's Oprah is a billionaire
okay but it's not has nothing yeah has
nothing to do with being on the uh
Beyonce
uh is a billionaire but has nothing to
do I spoke for 84 Lumber the other day
the lady that owns that second
generation 1.4 billion dollar net worth
oh wow 57 years old but that's the value
of 84 Lumber
it's a family business and it's huge you
know 250 stores okay uh nine billion
dollars in Revenue so uh you know so but
that that's not your 401k but that's a
billionaire which is way different I
mean millionaires they don't have Jets
okay the one to five million dollars you
don't need to spend 600 000 on jet
that's a bad idea so you got somebody
got a jet that's a billionaire or
hundreds of millions right they don't
have uh eight cars
they got two
most millionaires okay so this is the
difference in a millionaire and a
millionaire when you adjust that in your
mind then you go okay yeah I would like
to do more than a million sure I'd like
to do more than 10 million like your
guys on Tic Tac that were saying right
but the uh but this idea that somehow
you've got to go crazy and do stupid bus
stuff to get there that's a bad idea so
we're going to talk to real millionaires
this hour because we know it's not from
an inheritance on average
and we do know it's basic investing on
average but I want to hear it from real
people and regardless of your story
whether your story lines up with that or
not we want to talk to you triple eight
eight two five five two two five
foreign
[Music]
guys so if you're coming around
Nashville stop by Ramsey Solutions we've
got a wonderful Visitor Center an area
you can walk through bookstore free
cookies oh they're good and coffee and
you can watch the show we do the show on
the glass every day from one to four
Central Time and we'd love to have you
we always go out at the the commercial
breaks or some of the commercial breaks
and sign books and have pictures with
folks and there's generally 50 to a
couple hundred people depending on the
season hanging out with us out there is
talk to a guy named Jim out there a
minute ago uh 2.7 million dollar net
worth all in a paid for house and in his
retirement mutual funds yep and as I was
getting my coffee he said and he's like
tell your dad I'm wearing a pair of 10
year old blue jeans there you go that's
a classic Millionaire right there so
good James and Katie are in Ocean City
New Jersey what's you guys net worth
hey Gabe and Rachel uh our net worth is
uh one million thirty thousand awesome
you did it cool we did it I love it how
old are you guys
I'm 46. and I'm 41. good you're young
millionaires how much of the one million
thirty thousand was inherited
uh yeah zero okay cool and what has your
been your range of income since you guys
started working got married what best
year household income worst year
household income
um so in 2008
um we made 30 000 and then in 2021 we
made
548.
there's that what do you guys do for a
living
uh we're in real estate okay as Brokers
or investors
uh Brokers okay you have do you have
four-year degrees
I do I have a four-year degree and what
I uh in biblical studies okay yeah all
right which always sets you up to be a
real estate broker right okay exactly
right
what was your GPA in uh in in college
Kate Katie it was like 3.6 good okay so
break the million down for me how is
that uh invested what's it in
so
um between our Roth and stuff is about
200k
cash 325
our home 425 and then our vehicles a
little piece of land and 529.
Okay so
it sounds like listening to your what
I'm seeing in the numbers of your story
that basically you just earned a big
pile of Money Paid everything off and
piled up a big pile of cash
yeah in uh June of 2022 we did our debt
free screen
um so that
20 21 22 in real estate you know that
the numbers really jumped up and we
um had a couple of really strong years
that's so good was the debt free Scream
the house and everything
yeah so what would you say to someone
that's like they're on their Journey
maybe they've paid off all their
Consumer Debt they're working on the
house how how much
um like springboard is it for you guys
of not having a house payment and
obviously you're making great income but
how much was paying off that house that
really opened up some cash flow that you
felt
yeah for sure I mean not having a
mortgage changed everything
um we listened to your podcast it's just
weird talking to you because we I um
have like a side hustle business where I
clean and so um I would scrubbing
toilets listening to the podcast keeping
my heart my mind centered on why we were
doing this and just working really hard
to
um pay off debt and pay off our house
and
um yeah not having that mortgage is is
huge
man man it's amazing you guys I just I
want to go on a soapbox rant right now
the millionaire toilet scrubber
meanwhile you have people sitting around
in their mother's basement whining and
saying that America is broken and they
can't do anything while Katie goes and
makes some makes you know you guys bust
your butts and clean clean up literally
and then clean up figuratively that's
just that's fabulous I'm so proud of
y'all
and now you don't do that anymore right
you hire other people to do it right I
do yeah I have a great that's what I do
yep
yeah God told me I don't have to cut any
grass anymore
I cut enough grass in the first 20 years
of my life to have got I got my whole
quota in for my whole life it was great
yeah it's the same thing right so oh my
gosh you guys are incredible I'm so
proud of you okay I I know you guys are
extra Hustlers and uh in a good way
hustle grind hustle and grind uh but
talk to the people out there who think
it can't be done anymore can it
yeah absolutely
um I I did not go to college I barely
needed out of high school
um but I did we took FPU we LED four
fpus and I'm taking the financial Coach
master training right now
um so there's there's definitely it can
be done I never really planned on it or
thought we would hit that Mark I just
started doing the numbers and said to
Kate like oh we were there yeah you guys
drunk all the Kool-Aid man I mean thank
you thank you I like it well and look at
what it got you that's what's cool so
hey very proud of you guys
congratulations Heroes you did it I love
talking to somebody who cleaned enough
toilets that they never have to clean
another toilet yep isn't that great well
it's just the hardware and and the the
idea of hey I'm gonna go do a side
hustle while we're doing real estate as
well I mean all of it together was just
phenomenal so well done guys Nathan in
Northfield Minnesota what's your net
worth hello Dave my net worth is 1.3
million cool how old are you
44 and my wife is 43. very good another
young millionaire how much of this did
you inherit
um I inherited one thousand dollars last
year when my grandmother died well that
made a big difference yep
okay let me ride down one thousand
dollars all right so that's right uh
what has been your household income best
year and worse year since you all began
working and begin life
uh worst year was about 30 000 best year
was 240
000. excellent excellent and give me a
little breakdown on the 1.3 how's it
broken up
all right on the 1.3 our house is about
500. uh we own a commercial lot that we
have not put a building on yet at about
a hundred thousand uh retirement
accounts we have about three hundred
thirty thousand
um in business we're in construction and
Landscaping so we have quite a bit of um
trucks and equipments we've got about
250 000 of paid for equipment
and then we have a hundred and twenty
thousand of cash 529 emergency fund
personal vehicles that type of stuff way
to go excellent excellent so you own a
construction and landscape business
yep yep I run the construction side and
my wife runs the landscape side yep got
it awesome you got four-year degrees we
do not uh we both went to the local
technical school I went for a one-year
program in me cutting and my wife went
to the landscape program they had and
that was a two-year program at that time
in meat cutting yes I know it took a
year were you gonna do it were you gonna
be a butcher what was the thing uh yes
yeah I thought about doing that I worked
that industry for about a year and then
I decided I wanted to stick with
construction I bet you can feel dress a
deer oh absolutely yep I actually
slaughtered my own beef about two weeks
ago I had my own property here so yep I
love it what was your GPA or her GPA uh
mine was 3.97 but again it's me cutting
almost a 4.0
and then my wife I think it was like a
3.7 she said all right very good okay
cool cool congratulations man when did
you look up and realize gosh we're
millionaires
um so we did our we came to our
debt-free screen when you were at the
old building that was in 2018.
um so so this is two years ago like 2020
we became millionaires we were 42 and 41
and it was just kind of a progression
after paying let's be honest after you
pay your house off it happens fast after
that yeah yeah because you got cash flow
yep exactly you know we always say your
most powerful wealth building tool is
your income well when you pay your
freaking house off you see that exactly
yeah it's really legitimate so you guys
are kind of baby steps millionaires in a
sense you followed this stuff yes very
much so yeah we took FPU originally and
I believe was 2003
and then we taught Fu at our church from
2005 up to about 2020. just a couple of
years ago and we kind of we ran we ran
out of students shall we said our church
and we decided that was enough for a
little while at least let it recoup for
a few years and see if we pick it up
again thank you thanks for leading the
class and hey man you're a hero
congratulations way to go Dad come 44
year old millionaires I love this so
good it's a baby steps millionaires
female or we're talking to real
millionaires micro will love the meat
cutter millionaire toy he will love it
when I tell him that this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
but we talk about uh wealth here a lot
and it is about changing your family
tree it's about leaving a legacy but
it's also about giving like no one else
and that's a big part of this money
message that you want to be able to win
with money obviously for your presence
and for your future self and family but
also to help others so there was a fun
story that we came across
and there was a waiter Jordan
in at I guess the restaurant is
Charleston's in West Omaha
and he came in for work and heard that
he'd be serving a party of 18 people on
his March 7th shift and he greeted it
with a very upbeat attitude because he
said he likes to wait on large parties
because they usually like to have fun
and he enjoys it well the group turned
out to have it pop singer Jason Derulo
I feel like a boomer I don't know who he
I feel so out of touch I'm not sure who
he is but I'm sure you just have to give
up your cool cards she is great he's
amazing he is amazing because
he left a tip at the very ends and he
was a great you know the whole uh 18 of
his friends and him were wonderful and
pleasant because the waiter Jordan was
talking about just how kind they were
and great and so at the end of the night
he went and saw that Jason the pop
singer left a five thousand dollar tip
to this college student Jordan their
waiter and his tuition was due the next
week you just gave the best punchline
I'm sorry
that was the sweetest part of the whole
story his tuition was too like the next
day and the five thousand dollars
covered it so there you go
there you go
[Laughter]
that's like oh I'll tell the punchline
of the joke
hey there you go uh
yeah I mean that's that is awesome
that's why we work that's why we work
that's why you want to get here so that
you can have that moment uh he posted
about it and apparently
um
Jason Derulo posted back jerulo oh yeah
and um keep reading I threw my paper
yeah so you have to find your paper you
threw it on the floor but um
but yeah he posted on Tic Tac I mean
Tick Tock um and that was uh that was
pretty cool that's pretty cool that's
fun so you know the mythology is that
all wealth is inherited the mythology is
that rich people are all Crooks have you
heard that one
the percentage of rich people that are
Crooks is about the same percentage of
poor people that are Crooks
there's just some people that are Crooks
but it really doesn't have anything to
do with the money
you don't get money by being crooked and
keep it long term
I mean that's the dumbest set of
assumptions
because if you deal with someone and
they're a thief you deal with someone
and they don't have integrity and they
steal from you you deal with someone you
go to the car mechanic he doesn't fix
your car and charges you
and didn't change out any parts because
he's a crook
you don't go back
so you don't get repeat business when
you're a crook
you have to start over every time
so being a crook is much more work
than creating a good quality service and
people come back
it's a lot more work to be a crook
because you got to get all new clients
all the time you gotta get all new
victims all the time so when you people
out there when you hear people say I'll
rich people are Crooks see this all they
are is their victim mentality and
they're dealing with two evil spirits
called jealousy and envy
jealousy is I want what you have Envy is
I don't even want you to have it
there's I mean not only do I want what
you have but I don't even want you to
have what you have that's envy and
that's what's going around the culture
right now that's out of control all
millionaires are entertainers they're
Jason Derulo they're all uh pop stars
they're all country music stars or
basketball or football stars or whatever
it's less than one person of
millionaires are household names
celebrities
Sports oh I know who Jason is
I know who he is I get my cool card back
let me see it
oh yeah okay it's r b guy yep yeah okay
cool until I know who he is oh I feel
better about my my age
current events and you'd lost the punch
line I mean it's been a bad day for you
you took the punchline from me I didn't
lose it
all right and uh the other thing here
the other uh mythology about
millionaires is that they're all they're
all Geniuses they're all 4.2 oh yeah you
know they're like rocket surgeons or
something I mean uh you know this kind
of stuff they're they're not brain
surgeons and they're not rocket
scientists either one right they're neat
they're none of this the vast majority
of millionaires have a a 3.0 to a 3.5
GPA very few of them have a one point
something you can't be stupid and become
a millionaire you have to actually have
to have some brain cells working but you
do not have to be genius level okay you
don't have to be brilliant 4.2 I never
saw 4.2 except on my you know when I
fill up my car that's the only time I
see 4.2 all right uh here we go let's go
to uh Crystal uh in Olivia Minnesota
Crystal what's your net worth
okay cool how old are you guys
I'm 36 my husband is 37. and they're
getting younger by the call okay cool
and how much of the 1.3 did you guys
inherit
zero okay and give me a little breakdown
on the 1.3 what's the categories of it
uh we have about 125 000 in cash
755 000
our house is worth 220 000 and we own
that
um and then two hundred thousand dollars
in other assets
let me just make sure everybody in
America heard that you live as a
millionaire in a 220 000 house
I do yes we actually bought it for 78
000. yeah that's that's pretty typical
by the way but this idea that oh my God
if I don't have a four hundred thousand
dollar eight hundred thousand dollar
nine hundred thousand dollar house oh my
God that's not you
no no so what was your all's best year
household income since you've been
working in worst year
uh first year when we first got married
um combined income is about ninety
thousand
um our highest year was about 250 000.
cool what do y'all do for a living
uh my husband is a network administrator
who just
Corporate America and I'm gonna start my
own Clinic I like it love you love it
all right what was your uh you obviously
have a Nursing degree what was your GPA
uh so my undergrad was 3.2 and my
graduate degree was 4.0 okay nice and uh
your network engineer husband did he get
a four-year degree
uh he got a two-year degree
um and he had he had a 3.0 GP okay there
we go all right you guys have done this
very young how did you do it what's the
key
uh we actually followed all of your sets
um to put it into perspective in 2015 we
had a negative net worth of 125 000. we
became everyday millionaires in June of
2021. wow
we paid off 147 000 in 17 months
um that included our house I was taught
FPU twice
um it's just really just living by your
principles it's it makes it pretty easy
actually oh wow I'm gonna pay you for
the commercial well done well done thank
you FPU baby steps Millionaires and
that's a long road I mean it's uh we
talk about it too it doesn't happen
overnight yeah
about eight years from a negative net
worth to 1.3 but the diligence
throughout that eight years I'm like it
didn't happen in 24 months so so the the
long game that you guys continue to play
and we're diligent with the steps
diligent with your money gets this
result which is incredible absolutely
incredible
and as soon as we could I mean as soon
as we got out of debt we tried to max
out all of our retirement accounts as
much as possible I got my Rachel Cruz
while it's sitting right next to me yeah
girl I'm so glad yeah and it was always
it was always just kind of like a it was
kind of like a little goal right so our
goal was debt free by 33 and we paid off
our house three days before my husband's
33rd birthday
um and then I said we're gonna be
millionaires by 35 and he's like no
we're not going to be able to make it
and I was like No we're going to
um and by the time I turned 35 we were
millionaires yeah incredible 35 and 36
years old you're a hero girl so proud of
you for taking control of your life
improving to people all across America
22 million people just heard you say
this story
that's pretty cool and by the way her
story is real
in case you're wondering
this is a baby steps millionaires theme
hour
[Music]
foreign
our scriptures today James 2 18 but
someone will say you have faith and I
have Works show me your faith apart from
your works and I will show you my faith
by my works
Dale Carnegie said an action breeds
doubt and fear action reads confidence
and courage if you want to conquer fear
Do not sit home and think about it go
out and get busy like it it'll work for
me
it's a millionaire baby steps
millionaires theme hour paying off debt
saving and investing is smart but
there's one key to winning with money
that people Overlook and that's
protecting your finances there's 10
kinds of insurance coverage you might
need if you want to take the uh coverage
checkup tool and use it it's completely
free and we'll show you what you need by
importance
and connect you with a Ramsay trusted
insurance provider to help you get this
insurance in place if you want it's all
free takes about five minutes so go to
ramseysolutions.com checkup
ramseysolutions.com
checkup Eric is in Augusta Georgia Eric
what's your net worth
my net worth is uh 1.8 million cool how
old are you
I'm 32. my wife's 28. every every call
they get younger okay this is ridiculous
you're gonna have an 18 year old
dominion okay and uh uh how much of the
1.8 did you inherit
so we inherited it we didn't inherit any
money zero okay zero and uh breaker 1.8
down by category what give me a little
breakdown on it so 1.1 million is in
real estate uh primary home as well as
some rental real estate
um about 600 is in mutual funds Roth IRA
some company stock as well as some I
bonds and then 150 and 401K good for you
give me your best year household income
working Lifetime and worst year
so worst year when we came out we were
together making about 150. we did do a
few years of travel nursing so we uh
we're up to about 450 at one point in
time
um so it's kind of drastic uh spread
there but yeah you're back down to
something now about 300 or what right
around the 300 range now we just moved
back home we got a baby due coming up so
we finally decided to come home and get
settled down are you both nurses we are
both nurses yeah okay
cool so you got nursing degrees what was
your GPA and your nursing degrees
uh my GPA was around a three two three
three my wife's was a higher 3.9 okay
cool
cool so uh travel nursing uh coming off
of a pandemic were you guys in the
middle of that
travel nursing uh we were doing travel
nursing about a year before uh covet hit
and then we traveled through it and um
yeah up until about a month or two ago
was that scary
it was um yeah it was it was different
it was a very different world in the
hospital during that period of time um
for sure uh were you all scared
we were not personally yeah
um but I know every a lot of people
around us were we've traveled all
throughout the southeast so different
areas respond very differently to covet
during that time so well thanks for
y'all's work during that time I know
healthcare workers it was it was a lot a
lot on you guys so thank you yeah
absolutely yeah it was uh we went out uh
the Ramsey team one morning and right in
the middle all of that and went up to
the local hospital there's a gas station
in front and pumped gas for all of them
bought her by a tank of gas and had
scrubs on and man you could see the
strain in their eyes
yeah that period was a lot during those
few years was a lot of things seen that
a lot of people even in the field have
an experience so it was hard during
those periods yeah a couple years yeah
it's like a vacation now compared yeah
that's right yes definitely and a new
baby on the way congratulations maybe we
do two days from now oh my gosh Friday
enjoy your sleep tonight so what do you
uh yeah what do you uh what do you tell
people can they still do it today
yes definitely can still do today um
things are a little bit more expensive
so I think it's a little bit harder to
get there but you know hard work pays
off so if you if you're motivated by it
and you can you can definitely still get
there today proud of you hero in a bunch
of different ways Your Heroes thank you
thank you very much all right Lara is in
Tampa Lara your net worth
uh 34 million well look at that good for
you how old are you Laura I am 49 years
old good for you okay give me a little
breakdown I'm curious that's a great net
worth
so I've got uh 14 million in real estate
assets and then uh 20 million in my
business asset if I sold my business
today gotcha what kind of business have
you got
I'm a franchisor of a disaster
restoration concept ah gotcha okay
excellent excellent how much of this did
you inherit
zero wow dug it out with your fingers
huh literally yeah I I started out as a
28 000 a year police officer
um 20 some years ago and then
decided uh poverty wasn't for me so I
started my company when I was 31 years
old
dang I love that I just decided I don't
like poverty so I'm not going to do it
I'm not going to do it that's really
what it is it's a choice it really is
well apparently yeah
all right so the real estate guy came
from the fact that you made so much
money in the business
yeah correct and then you make more
money on the real estate after buying it
yeah and I kept a bunch of uh rentals I
got about 13 or 14 rentals right now and
uh if the business went down the tubes
tomorrow I could live off the rentals
forever yeah 14 million I think you
could yeah yeah yeah unless 12 million's
your house I don't know but yeah what's
your personal residence worth
it's worth about 1
. why pay it off okay and the uh yeah
and the uh uh do you have another house
you have a do you have a toy house a
vacation or something Beach or cat
Mountain I don't all Investments no toy
houses okay you need to get one of those
too okay yeah I'm working on it all
right so what's your dream on that uh
how a mountain or a beach or a lake or
what a mountain I'm at the beach right
now so like
Florida so Mountain would be be the way
to go for me yeah it'd be perfect like
Highlands or North Carolina or something
yeah yes exactly exactly how did you
grow up Laura
be part of your story
middle class but uh once I got to
college I was actually on food stamps
um just to get through college uh my
loans didn't cover enough uh to pay my
living and my school my books all that
stuff so I had a couple jobs and I was
on food stamps for a while so it's it's
very surreal to be in the position I'm
in now I take it from the language
you're using that you're single
yes okay always single
uh no I'm divorced okay how long ago
uh four or five years oh wow fairly
recent okay all right so this this all
survived that
well I have a great lawyer apparently
yeah and uh good prenups yeah good good
okay all right because you are you are
you're you're a warrior I mean you're an
Amazon woman for sure it's amazing I'm
you're impressive I love it thank you
best best net worth call in uh highest
net worth in the last several of these
shows uh we had one we had one that was
55 million one time and um oh wow you
know that kind of stuff but the guy
owned a bunch of restaurants and uh
we've had a few others but you you're a
rock star I mean you're amazing you
can't say Rockstar anymore after the
dead gun Super Bowl commercial but the
uh but yeah you're amazing thank you
you're you're incredible all right tell
uh uh your 49 year old lady that's
divorced and you're worth 34 million
dollars tell a 24 year old lady out
there who's struggling and scared that
she can do it
oh absolutely I in my opinion I know
other people probably disagree with me I
think it's easier now than it was back
then just because of the internet and
all of the ability for affiliate
marketing businesses and there's just so
much more opportunity now than there was
when I was first starting
I agree it is probably the best time in
the history of the world I couldn't
agree yeah start a business and run a
business and take a service to Market a
product to Market this serves people and
you the wealth that can be gotten
because of that in the process of
helping people it's amazing I mean
selling books on the Internet is a lot
easier than selling them through
bookstores oh absolutely you know it's
just it's a lot easier because sometimes
bookstores are stupid you know yeah you
know it's just you know it's just it's
it's exactly it's just a it's a
wonderful time I agree love that advice
and I love that encouragement great job
Laura Laura you're amazing thank you for
calling in a baby steps millionaires
female or that puts a little icing on
the cake with Miss Laura I know that was
a great call to end it well done any uh
any any other questions out there I
think we just answered them all
you can do it you can do it you're not a
victim Lara wasn't a victim never was
that woman a victim this
there's the Ramsay show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]